well new at six getting your car fixed
is never convenient now it's even less
so madison cambro explains wait times
are stretching into months
the demand for service appointments is
higher than ever with more drivers
hanging on to their older vehicles
making the need for repair and basic
checkups common take a look as 8 news
now viewers chimed in on social
expressing their frustration over the
matter tyler quarter at findlay lincoln
in henderson says it's a combination of
a lot of factors causing this issue in a
lot of our dealerships we've seen a 15
to 20 percent increase in the number of
service tickets we write this month
compared to the same time last year so
we've got a little bit of a part
shortage you got
some staffing issues in cases and you've
got increased demand and all that it
kind of leads up to why sometimes it's
difficult to get a car in for service
here at ted wien's complete auto service
they are seeing more and more older
vehicles like the ones that you see
right here come in for maintenance and
unfortunately due to the parts needed
and lack of labor it's taking longer
than usual hearts
and tires
they're they're in such high demand
we're looking sometimes at six to eight
weeks just for the parts
well ted wins complete auto service says
it isn't the appointment booking as much
as it is the wait time so be prepared to
wait a good three to four hours for your
typical service check